Jack I can only imagine what's going on
in your head right now
[Music]
every day you're on the Run you're
digging a hole that you may not be able
to get out of
it I'm not running from the CIA
then why are they chasing you
Hardline Russians
formed a plan to preserve the USSR use a
nuclear strike to create chaos the
weapon has been built and it is on the
move
the US can't go anywhere near this we
don't have any wiggle room to make
mistakes if you don't come in you will
be recalled I come in now a whole lot of
people are gonna die
you're about to cross the line and there
may be no going back because I'm trying
to do the right thing
it was never just about a nuke this is
about starting a World War
Jesus someone was playing a very
dangerous game we got two eliminated
jacket every second man is
what are you doing improvising
[Music]
in fact if you've got a plan the time is
now
I want Jack Ryan in custody immediately
so what are the odds this is a one-way
trip 80 90 that's my last fight won't be
in coach